we are still focused on that mass
shooting in buffalo where a young white
man is accused of killing 10 black
people at a grocery store president
biden and the first lady will travel to
the city this morning to meet with
families of those killed and mr biden is
also expected to visit the tops friendly
market that the gunman targeted and
we're learning more about the lives of
the victims as well we'll have more on
that in a moment national correspondent
drika duncan has been doing tremendous
reporting there talking with family
members and others in the community but
first we're going to go to jeff begays
who has the latest on the police
investigation jeff good morning
good morning law enforcement sources
tell cbs news that the alleged gunman
purchased the ar-15 style weapon
used in that attack legally they also
believe that he intended to continue his
killing spree at other locations after
scouting specific targets for months
the individual was here a few months ago
back in early march authorities believe
the suspect scoped out the site of
saturday's shooting two months in
advance in an online post the 18 year
old allegedly wrote that he'd been
confronted by a security guard at the
time and referred to the interaction as
a close call the attack at the top
supermarket comes amid a steady rise in
hate crimes nationwide from around 5800
in 2015 to more than 8 000 in 2020 it is
no surprise in many ways that this
shooter in buffalo tried to live stream
his attack signaling back to the
communities online to say this is how
you do it orrin siegel tracks extremists
for the anti-defamation league he told
us that racially motivated killings like
this one
give other extremists a blueprint for
their own acts of violence what are you
seeing online
48 hours out from this shooting we are
seeing
extremists share the manifesto we are
seeing them share the video of the
attack we are seeing them
glorify
this individual a document allegedly
linked to the gunman reveals his belief
in replacement theory a racist and
anti-semitic conspiracy that there is a
plot to replace white people with people
of color this is not something that is
simply on the fringes this is also a
theory that we are hearing from elected
officials and from some of our broadcast
news a recent associated press poll
shows that roughly a third of americans
believe an effort is underway to replace
people born in the u.s with immigrants
for electoral gains republicans are more
likely to harbor that belief monday
republican congresswoman liz chaney
called on her colleagues to reject such
views tweeting the house gop leadership
has enabled white nationalism white
supremacy and anti-semitism we have been
made aware of many social media posts
going around with possible threats
officials now say that they're concerned
about copycats police arrested a buffalo
man who they say referenced the top
shooting and calls to a pizzeria and a
brewery he's been charged with making a
terrorist threat this is what's going to
happen if you make threats
you are going to get arrested
and then i am going to prosecute you
the suspect in the weekend killing spree
pleaded not guilty to a murder charge he
is expected in court on thursday right
now he's in a jail cell behind me
nate
jeff thank you